[Music]
after a grounded start with the first
movie sonic the hedgehog 2 looks a lot
more like the games that inspired it so
much so that if you're behind on your
sonic law you might not know what's
going on especially with that post
credit scene this is the ending of sonic
2 explained sonic meet knuckles
the motivations of the angry red echidna
knuckles actually tie into the opening
of the first son of the hedgehog movie
in these moments we see how sonic ended
up on earth in our human world sonic was
raised by the owl at longclaw on a
mystical island that was peaceful for
the most part when the owls were invaded
by a kidneys longclaw gives her powerful
rings to sonic and sends him far away to
safety in sonic the hedgehog 2 we get
more perspective on these events from an
echidna following sonic's departure a
battle ensued that wiped out a majority
of the fighting echidnas knuckles was
one of the young survivors and the
events of that day radically changed him
sending him on a revenge field quest
knowing that sonic was raised by lonclaw
knuckles makes the hedgehog his sworn
enemy and vows to find him and take him
down
when he learns of the echidna's
existence robotnik tracks down and
manipulates knuckles into helping him
find one of the world's largest sources
of power the master emerald
knuckles main motivation in wiping out
sonic is revenge for the owl's slaughter
of his people but there's also the
important element of the master emerald
knuckles feels it's his destiny to seek
out the all-powerful stone and he plans
on using it as a tool to stop sonic once
and for all while the movie gives a
brief lord dump it doesn't get into why
the master emerald is so important to
this character to know that you'll need
to look to the video games in the game
lore knuckles also began as a villain
who worked with robotnik although
eventually we learn he was tricked by
him into teaming up as his backstory in
the games gets fleshed out we learn
knuckles as the last living echidna of
his tribe and a swan protector of the
master emerald in the movie he dabbles
with the possibility of using the
emerald's power for his own selfish
needs by the end of the movie knuckles
has undergone a change and becomes a
great protector that fans know and love
this reflects the arc the character had
in his first hand full of game
appearances
for a guy named knuckles you are really
bad at punching any adult paying
attention could see that robotnik was
destined to betray knuckles by the end
of the movie the evil genius use the
echidna's blinding rage to manipulate
knuckles into steering him right to the
master emerald the moment the precious
or powerful stone is in sight robotnik
realizes knuckles is a threat that must
be eliminated robotnig takes a master
emerald for himself and makes an attempt
to get rid of sonic and knuckles for
good sonic rescues knuckles which leaves
the echidna to re-evaluate his
relationship with the hedgehog and his
fox companion this change of heart leads
to a team-up that will end up taking
down robotnik for good this story arc
follows the basics laid down by some of
the early sonic the hedgehog games in
sonic and knuckles on genesis sonic
fights knuckles only for both of them to
find out it was a stage distraction for
robotnik to steal the master emerald the
plot of the movie follows these beats
pretty faithfully
sonic knuckles and tails work together
to thwart dr robotnik and his egg
smasher mech as knuckles punches a robot
hard enough to break the emerald out of
it we see the master emerald break into
smaller shards for a second there it
seems like all hope is lost for knuckles
and his quest to find and protect the
emerald but then a miracle happens sonic
absorbs shards of the master emerald and
they power him up transforming the blue
hedgehog we've come to know into a
glowing yellow supersonic with this
enhanced power sonic is able to defeat
robotnik and his egg smasher for good
after his purpose is completed
supersonic reverts back to normal and
the emeralds exit his body to once more
form one whole master emerald supersonic
made its debut in the genesis game sonic
the hedgehog 2. since then super sonic
has appeared in dozens of sonic games
often as an unlockable character in the
story of the games he is the evolution
of sonic after he collects all seven
chaos emeralds which is often the main
objective of any given sonic game
in the post-credits scene of sonic the
hedgehog 2 we see agents of gunn aka the
guardian units of nations stumble upon a
top secret project from over 50 years
ago the name is revealed to be project
shadow and we are shown an extremely
brief glimpse of a large tube with a
figure inside the last shot of the movie
is a black figure inside opening his red
eyes
yes that's you
fans i grew up on the late dreamcast and
gamecube era of sonic games will
recognize this as shadow the hedgehog
this edgy foil to sonic is so extreme
that he even used the gun and shadowed
the hedgehog the sonic spin-off game
that was actually released and wasn't
just a mid-2000s fever dream shadow
first appeared in sonic adventure 2 and
he was a staple character for that
generation of sonic even making his way
to become a character on the cartoon
network show sonic boom this tease
suggests shadow will play a role in the
next sonic movie possibly as the villain
this isn't the most shocking move but it
is one fans have been waiting to see for
quite a long time
it makes complete sense for shadow to
join the cinematic universe on the next
sonic adventure broadening the universe
of sonic on screen the games have long
had a large and growing roster of
characters but someone new being
introduced in seemingly every game first
release for the dreamcast 1998 sonic
adventure brought sonic tails and a
whole new roster of foes and friends
into 3d for the first time ever it also
introduced new heroes like big the cat
and helped give new life to older
characters like amy rose a bouncy female
hedgehog who eventually develops a huge
crush on sonic with the shadow tees at
the end of this movie it seems natural
that the next sonic story could bring
more of these game characters into the
fold also introduced in sonic cd is
metal sonic a robot recreation of the
hedgehog engineered by robotnik this is
one of the most iconic enemy designs in
the game franchise and has yet to appear
in the movies and what about the
scheming rouge the bat another semi
villainous sonic foil will she cross
over into this universe too only time
will tell
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]